all right so let's get started so thank
you all for coming to day two of six
s-191 we're really excited to to have
you for these two lectures and lab today
which are largely going to be focused on
deep learning for computer vision so to
motivate I think we can all agree that
vision is one of the most important
human senses and sighted people rely on
vision quite a lot for everything from
navigating in the physical world to
recognizing and manipulating objects to
interpreting facial expressions and
understanding emotion and I think it's
safe to say that for many of for all of
us or many of us vision is a huge part
of our lives and that's largely thanks
to the power of evolution evolutionary
biologists traced the origins of vision
back 540 million years ago to the
Cambrian explosion and the reason that
vision seems so easy for us as humans is
because we have 540 million years of
data that evolution has effectively
trained on and if you compare that to
other capabilities like bipedal movement
and language the difference is is quite
significant and starting in the 1960s
there was a surge of interest in both
the neural basis of vision and how to
systematically characterize visual
processing and this led to computer
scientists beginning to wonder about how
findings in neuroscience could be
applied to achieve artificial computer
vision and it all started with these
series of seminal experiments from two
neuroscientists David Hubel and Torsten
vessel who were working at Harvard at
the time and they were looking at
processing in the visual cortex of cats
and what they were able to demonstrate
was that their neural mechanisms for
spatially invariant pattern recognition
and that certain neurons in the visual
cortex respond very specifically to
specific patterns and regions of visual
stimuli and furthermore that there's an
exquisite hierarchy
of neural layers that exist within the
visual cortex and these concepts have
transformed both neuroscience and
artificial intelligence alike and today
we're going to learn about how to use
deep learning to build powerful computer
vision systems that have been have been
shown to be capable of extraordinary
complex computer vision tasks so now
that we've gone in a sense at a very
high level of why this is important and
sort of how our brains may process
visual information we can turn our
attention to what computers see how does
a computer process an image so well to a
computer images are just numbers so
suppose we have this picture of Abraham
Lincoln it's made up of pixels and since
this is a grayscale image each of these
pixels is just a single number and we
can represent this image as a 2d matrix
of numbers one for each pixel in the
image and this is how a computer sees
this image likewise if we were to have a
RGB color image not grayscale we can
represent that with a 3d array where now
we have two D matrices for each of the
channels are g and b so now that we have
a way to represent images to computers
we can think about what types of
computer computer vision tasks we can
perform and two very common types of
tasks and machine learning broadly are
those of regression and those of
classification in a regression our
output takes a continuous value while in
classification our output takes a single
class label so for example let's
consider the task of image
classification say we want to predict a
single label for some image and let's
say we have a bunch of images of US
presidents and we want to build a
classification pipeline to tell us which
President is in an image outputting the
probability that that image is of a
particular President and so you can
imagine right that in order to cry
classified these images our pipeline
needs to be able to tell what is unique
about a picture of Lincoln versus a
picture of Washington versus a picture
of Obama and another way to think about
this problem at a high level is in terms
of the features that are characteristic
of a particular class and classification
it can then be thought of as involving
detection of the features in a given
image and sort of deciding okay well if
the feature is for a particular class
are present in an image we can then
predict that that image is of that class
with a higher probability and so if
we're building a image classification
pipeline our model needs to know what
those features are and it needs to be
able to detect those features in an
image in order to generate this
prediction one way to solve this problem
is to leverage our knowledge about a
particular field say those of human
faces and use our prior knowledge to
define those features ourselves and so a
classification pipeline would then try
to detect these manually defined
features and images and use the results
of some sort of detection algorithm to
do the classification but there's a big
problem with this approach and if you
remember images are just 3d arrays of
effectively brightness values and they
can have lots and lots and lots of
variation such as occlusion variations
in illumination and intraclass variation
and if we want to build a robust
pipeline for doing this classification
task our model has to be invariant to
these variations while still being
sensitive to the differences that define
the individual classes even though our
pipeline could use these features that
we the human define where this manual
extraction will break down is actually
in the detection task and that's again
due to the incredible variability in
visual data because of this the
detection of these features is
actually really difficult in practice
because your detection algorithm would
need to withstand each of these
different variations so how can we do
better we want a way to both extract
features and detect their presence in
images automatically in a hierarchical
fashion and again right you came to a
class on deep learning we we we
hypothesize right that we could use a
neural network based approach to learn
visual features directly from data
without any you know manual definition
and to learn a hierarchy of these
features to construct a representation
of the image that's internal to the
network for example if we wanted to be
able to classify images of faces maybe
we could learn how to detect low-level
features like edges and dark spots mid
level features like eyes ears and noses
and then high level features that
actually resemble facial structure and
we'll see how neural networks will allow
us to directly learn these visual
features from visual data if we
construct them cleverly going back in
lecture 1 right we learned about fully
connected architectures where you can
have multiple hidden layers and where
each neuron in a given layer is
connected to every single neuron in the
subsequent layer and let's say that we
wanted to use a fully connected neural
network for image classification in this
case our 2d input image is transformed
into a vector of pixel values and this
vector is then fed into the network
where each neuron in the hidden in the
first hidden layer is connected to all
neurons in the input layer and here
hopefully you can appreciate that by
squashing our 2d our 2d matrix into this
1d vector and defining these fully
connected connections all spatial
information is completely lost
furthermore in in defining the network
in this way we end up having men
many different parameters right you need
a different weight parameter for every
single neural connection in your network
because it's fully connected and this
means that training in network like this
on a task like image classification
becomes infeasible in practice
importantly right visual data has this
really rich spatial structure how can we
leverage this to inform the architecture
of the network that we design to do this
let's represent our 2d input image as an
array of pixel values like I mentioned
before and one way we can immediately
use the spatial structure that's
inherent to this input is to connect
patches of the input to neurons in the
hidden layer another way of thinking
about this is that each neuron in a
hidden layer only sees a particular
region of what the input to that layer
is and this not only reduces the number
of weights in our model but also allows
us to leverage the fact that in an image
pixels that are spatially close to each
other are probably somehow related and
so I'd like you to really notice how the
only region how only a region of the
input layer influences this particular
neuron and we can define connections
across the whole input by applying the
same principle of connecting patches in
the input layer to neurons in the
subsequent subsequent layer and we do
this by actually sliding the patch
window across the input image in this
case we're sliding it by two units and
in doing this we take into account the
spatial structure that's inherent to the
input but remember right that our
ultimate task is to learn visual
features and the way we achieve this is
by weighting these connections between
the patch and the neuron and the neuron
in the next layer so as to detect
particular features so this this
principle is is called
we think of what you can think of it as
is applying a filter essentially a set
of weights to extract some sort of local
features that are present in your input
image and we can apply multiple
different filters to extract different
types of features and furthermore we can
spatially share the parameters of each
of these filters across the input so
that features that matter in one part of
the image will still matter elsewhere in
the image in practice this amounts to
this patchy operation that's called
convolution and if we first think about
this at a high level suppose we have a
four by four filter which means we have
16 different weights right and we're
going to apply this same filter to four
by four patches in the input and use the
result of that filter operation to
define the state of the neuron that the
patch is connected to right then we're
going to shift our filter over by a
certain width like two pixels grab the
next patch and apply that filtering
operation again and this is how we can
start to think about convolution at a
really high level but you're probably
wondering how does this actually work
what am I talking about when I keep
saying oh features extract visual
features how does this convolution
operation allow us to do this so let's
make this concrete by walking through a
couple of examples suppose we want to
classify X's from a set of black and
white images of letters where black is
equal to minus 1 and white is
represented by a value of 1 to classify
it's it's really not possible to simply
compare the two matrices to see if
they're equal because we want to be able
to classify and act as an X even if it's
transformed rotated reflected deformed
etc instead we want our model to compare
the images of an X piece by piece and
those important pieces that it learns to
look for are the features and
our model can get rough feature matches
in roughly the same positions relatively
speaking in two different images it can
get a lot better sense at seeing the
similarity between different examples of
exes so each feature is like a mini
image right
a small two-dimensional array of values
and we can use these filters to pick up
on the features that are common to exes
so in the case of exes right filters
that can pick up on diagonal lines and a
crossing capture what's important about
an X so we can probably capture these
features in the arms and center of any
image of an X and I'd like you to notice
that these smaller matrices are the
filters of weights that we'll actually
use to detect the corresponding features
in the input image now all that's left
is to define an operation that picks up
where these features pop up in our image
and that operation is convolution and
convolution is able to preserve the
spatial relationship between pixels by
learning image features in small squares
of the input and to do this what we do
is we simply perform an element-wise
multiplication between the filter weight
matrix and the patch of the input image
of the same dimensions and this results
in this case in a three by three matrix
and here in this example all the entries
in this matrix are 1 and that's because
everything is black and white either
minus 1 and 1 and this indicates that
there is a perfect correspondence
between our filter matrix and the patch
of the input image where we multiplied
it right so this is our filter this is
our patch they directly correspond and
the result is is as follows finally if
we add all the elements of this of this
matrix this is the result of convolving
this 3x3 filter with that particular
region of the input
and we get back to number nine so let's
consider another example right right to
hopefully drive this home even further
suppose we want to compute the
convolution of this 5x5 representation
of an image and this 3x3 filter to do
this we need to cover the entirety of
the input image by sliding this filter
over over the over the image performing
this element wise multiplication at each
step and adding the outputs that result
after each element wise multiplication
so let's see what this looks like first
we start off in this upper left corner
we multiply this filter by the values of
our of our input image and add the
result and we end up with the value of 4
this results in the first entry in our
output matrix which we can call the
feature map we next slide the 3 by 3
filter over by 1 to grab the next patch
and repeat this element wise
multiplication in addition this gives us
our second entry 3 we continue this
process until we have covered the
entirety of this input image
progressively sliding our filter to
cover it doing this element wise
multiplication patch by patch adding the
result and filling out our feature map
and that's it
that's convolution and this feature map
right this is a toy example but in
practice you can imagine that this
feature map reflects where in the input
image was activated by this filter where
in the input image that filter picked up
on right because higher values are going
to represent like sort of a greater
activation if you will and so this is
really the the bare-bones mechanism of
this convolution operation and to
consider really how powerful this is
different different different weight
filters can be used to produce distinct
feature Maps so this is a very fit
famous picture of this woman who's
called Lenna and as you can see here in
these three examples we've taken three
different filters applied this filter to
the same input image and generated three
very different outputs and as you can
see by simply changing the weights of
the filters we can detect we can detect
and extract different features like
edges that are present in the input
image this is really really powerful so
hopefully you can now appreciate how
convolution allows us to capitalize on
the spatial structure that's inherent in
visual data and use these sets of
weights to extract local features and we
can very easily detect different
features simply by applying different
filters and these concepts of preserving
spatial structure and local feature
extraction using these convolutions are
at the core of the neural networks used
for computer vision tasks which are
called convolutional neural networks or
CNN's so sort of with these bare bones
mechanism under our belt we can think
about how we can utilize this to build
neural networks for computer vision
tasks so let's first consider a CNN
designed for image classification
remember the goal here is to learn
features directly from the image data
this means learning the weights of those
filters and using these learned feature
maps for classification of these images
now there are three main operations to a
CNN the first is convolution which we
went through right and we saw how we can
apply these filters to generate future
maps the second is applying
non-linearity the same concept from
lecture one and the third key idea is
pooling which is effectively like a down
sampling operation to reduce the size of
of a map and finally the computation of
class scores and actually outputting a
prediction for the class of an image is
achieved by a fully connected layer at
the end of our network and so in
training we train our model on a set of
images and we actually learn those
weights of the filters that are going to
be used in the network as well as the
weights in the fully connected layer and
we'll go through each of these to break
down this basic architecture of CNN
so first right as we've already seen
let's consider the convolution operation
as before each neuron in a hidden layer
will compute a weighted sum of its
inputs apply a bias and activate with a
non-linearity that's the same exact
concept from lecture one but what's
special here is this local connectivity
the fact that each neuron in a hidden
layer is only seeing a patch of what
comes before it and so this relation
defines how neurons and convolutional
layers are connected what it boils down
to is the same idea of applying a window
of weights computing the linear
combination of those weights against the
input and then activating with non with
a nonlinear activation function after
applying a bias another thing we can
think about is the fact that within a
single convolutional layer we can
actually have many different filters
that we are learning different sets of
weights to be able to extract different
features and so the output layer after a
convolution operation will have a volume
where the height and the width are the
spatial dimensions dependent on the
input layer so if we had say a 40 by 40
input image the width and height would
be 40 by 40 assuming that you know the
dimensionality scales after the
operation and and these dimensions are
dependent on the size of the filter as
well as the
degree to which we're sliding it over
the over the input layer finally the
depth is defined by the number of
different filters that we we are using
the last key thing that I would like to
like for you to keep in mind is this
notion of the receptive field which is
essentially a term to describe the fact
that locations and input layers and are
connected to excuse me a neuron in a
downstream layer is only connected to a
particular location in its in its
respective input layer and that is
termed its receptive field okay so this
kind of at a high level explains sort of
how these convolutional operations work
in within convolutional layers the next
step that I mentioned is applying a
non-linearity to the output of a
convolutional layer and exactly the same
concept as the first lecture we do this
because image data is highly nonlinear
right and in CNN's it's very common
practice to apply nonlinearities after
every convolution operation that is
after each convolutional layer and the
most common activation function that is
used is called the relu function which
is essentially a pixel by pixel
operation that reply replaces all
negative values that follow from a
convolution with zero and you can think
of this as sort of a threshold incurring
indicates sort of negative direction of
a negative detection of that associated
feature the final key operation in cnn's
is pooling and pooling is a operation
that's used to reduce dimensionality and
to preserve spatial invariants and a
common technique is called max pooling
it's shown in this example and it's
exactly what it sounds you simply take
the maximum value in a patch in this
case a 2x2 patch that is is being
applied with a stride of 2 over this
over this array and the key idea here is
that we're reducing the dimensionality
going from one layer to the next and I
encourage you to think about other ways
in which we can perform this sort of
down sampling operation so these are the
three key operations to cnn's
and we're now ready to put them together
to actually construct our network and
with cnn's the key the key is that we
can layer these operations
hierarchically and by layering them in
this way our network can be trained to
learn a hierarchy of features present in
the image data so CNN for image
classification can be broken down into
two parts first this feature learning
pipeline where we learn features in our
input images through convolution and
through these convolutional layers and
finally the the second half is that
these convolutional and pooling layers
will output high level features that are
present in the input images and we can
then pass these features on to fully
connected layers to actually do the
classification task and these fully
connected layers can effectively output
a probability distribution for the
images membership over a set of possible
classes and a common way that this is
achieved is using this function called
the softmax whose output represents a
categorical probability distribution
over the set of classes that you're
interested in okay so the final key
piece right is how do we train this and
it's the same idea as we introduced in
lecture 1 back propagation the important
thing to keep in mind is what it is
we're learning when we're training SIA
what we learn when we train a CNN model
is the weights of those convolution
filters at another degree of abstraction
right you can think of this as what
features the network is learning to
detect in addition we also learn the
weights for the fully connected layers
if we're performing a classification
task and since our output in this case
is going to be a probability
distribution we can use that cross
entropy loss that was introduced in
lecture 1 to optimize via back
propagation so arguably the most famous
example of cnn's and for cnn's for
classification and maybe cnn's in
general is those trained and tested on
the famous imagenet data set an image
net is a massive data set with over 14
million images across over 20,000
different categories and this was
created and curated by a lab at Stanford
and is really become a very widely used
data set across a machine learning so
just to take an example in image net
there are 1,400 nine different pictures
of bananas and even better than the size
of this data set I really appreciated
their description of what a banana is
succinctly described as an elongated
crescent-shaped yellow fruit with soft
sweet / which both gives a pretty good
description of what a banana is and
speaks to its obvious deliciousness
so the creators of image net also
created a set of visual recognition
challenges on their data set and most
notably the image net classification
task which is really simple it's
produced a list of the object different
object categories that are present in
images across a ground truth set of
1,000 different categories
and in this competition they measured
the accuracy of the models that were
submitted in terms of the rate at which
the model did not output the correct
label in its top five predictions for a
particular image and the results of this
image net classification challenge are
pretty astonishing 2012 was the first
time a CNN won the challenge and this
was the famous CNN called Alex net and
since then the neural networks that have
have neural networks have completely
dominated this competition and the error
that the state of the art is able to
achieve keeps decreasing and decreasing
surpassing human error in 2015 with the
famous ResNet Network which had 152
convolutional layers in its design but
with improved accuracy the number of
layers in these networks has steadily
been increasing so take it as what you
will you know there's something to be
said about building deeper and deeper
networks to achieve higher and higher
accuracies so so far we've only talked
about classification but in truth CNN's
are extremely flexible architecture and
have been shown to be really powerful
for a number of different applications
and when we considered a CNN for
classification I showed this general
pipeline schematic where we had two
parts the feature learning part and the
classification part and what makes a
convolutional neural network a
convolutional neural network is really
this feature learning portion and after
that we can really change the second
part to suit the application that we
desire so for example this portion is
going to look different for different
image classification domains and we can
also introduce new architectures for
different types of tasks such as object
recognition segmentation and the image
captioning so I'd like to consider
three different applications of CNN's
beyond image classification the first is
semantic segmentation where the task is
to assign each pixel in the image an
object class to produce a segmentation
of the image object detection where we
want to detect instances of specific
objects in the image and finally image
captioning where the task is to generate
a language description of the image that
captures its semantic meaning so first
let's talk about semantic segmentation
with this architecture called fully
convolutional networks or f c ends and
here the way it works is the network
takes in an input of arbitrary size and
produces an output of of corresponding
size where each pixel has been assigned
an object class which we can then
visualize as a segmentation and so as
before we have a series of convolutional
layers arranged in this hierarchical
fashion to create this learned hierarchy
of features but then we can supplement
this these down sampling operations with
up sampling operations that increase the
resolution of the output from those
feature learning layers and then you can
combine the output from these up
sampling layers with those from the down
sampling layers to actually produce a
segmentation one application of this
sort of architecture is to the real-time
segmentation of driving scenes so this
was a results from a couple years ago
where the authors were using this
encoder decoder like structure where you
have down sampling layers followed by up
sampling layers to to produce these
these segmentations and last year this
was sort of the state of the art
performance that you could achieve with
an architecture like this in in doing
semantic segment
pation and deep learning is moving
extremely fast and now the new state of
the art in semantic segmentation is what
you see here and it's actually the same
the same authors as that previous result
but with an improved architecture where
now they're using one network trained to
do three tasks simultaneously semantic
segmentation shown here depth estimation
and instant segmentation which means
identifying different instances of the
same object type and as you can see in
this upper right corner
these segmentation results are pretty
astonishing and they've they
significantly improved in terms of their
crypts crispness compared to the
previous result another way CNN's have
been extended is for object detection
where here the task is to learn features
that characterize particular regions of
the input image then classify those
regions as belonging to particular
object classes and the pipeline for
doing this is is an architecture called
our CNN and it's pretty straight forward
so given an input image this algorithm
extracts a set of region proposals
bottom-up computes features for these
proposals using convolutional layers and
then classifies each region proposal and
there have been many many different
approaches to computing these different
computing and estimating these region
proposals step two in this in this
pipeline and as this has resulted in a
number of different extensions of this
of this general principle the final
application that I'd like to consider is
image captioning and so suppose we're
given this image of a cat riding the
skateboard in classification our task
could be to output the class label for
this particular image cat and as we saw
this is done by feeding the image
through a set of convolutional layers to
extract features and then a set of fully
connected
to generate a prediction in image
captioning what we want to do is
generate a sentence that describes the
semantic content of the image so if we
take that same CNN Network from before
and instead of fully connected layers at
the end we replace it with an RNN what
we can do is we can use a set of
convolutional layers to extract visual
features encode them in put them into a
recurrent neural network which we
learned about yesterday and then
generate a sentence that describes the
semantic content that's present in that
image and the reason we can do this is
that the output of these convolutional
layers gives us a fixed length encoding
that initializes our that we can use to
initialize an RNN and train it on this
captioning task so these are three very
concrete fundamental applications of of
CNN's but to take it a step further in
terms of sort of the depth and breadth
of impact that these sort of
architectures have had across a variety
of fields I'd like to first appreciate
the fact that these advances would not
have been possible without the curation
and availability of large well annotated
image datasets and this is what has been
fundamental to really rapidly
accelerating the progress in the
development of convolutional neural
networks and so some really famous
examples of image data sets are shown
here amnesty in today's lab image net
which I already mentioned and the places
data set which is out of MIT of
different scenes and landscapes and as I
as I sort of alluded to the impact of
these sorts of approaches has been
extremely far-reaching and and deep no
pun intended
and one area that convolutional neural
networks have been have made a really
big impact is in face detection and
recognition software and this is you
know every time you pick up your phone
this your your phone is running these
sorts of algorithms to pick up you know
your face and your friends face and this
type of software is pretty much
everywhere from social media to security
and in today's lab you'll have the
chance to build a CNN based architecture
for facial detection and you'll actually
take this a step further by exploring
how these how these models can be
potentially biased based on the nature
of the training data that they use
another application area that has led to
a lot of excitement is in autonomous
vehicles and self-driving cars so the
man in this video was a guest lecturer
that we had last year and he was really
fun and dynamic and this is work from
Nvidia where they have this pipeline
where they take a single image from a
camera on the car feed it into a CNN
that directly outputs a single number
which is a predicted steering wheel
angle and Beyond self-driving cars
NVIDIA has a really large-scale research
effort that's focused on computer vision
and on Friday we'll hear from the leader
of Nvidia's entire computer vision team
and he'll talk about some of the latest
and greatest research that they're doing
there finally there's been a pretty
significant impact of of these types of
architectures in medicine and healthcare
where deep learning models are being
applied to the analysis of a whole host
of types of medical images so this is a
paper from Nature Medicine from just a
few weeks ago where it was a multi
Institute team and they presented a CNN
that uses a pretty standard architecture
to identify rare genetic conditions from
analysis of just a picture of a child's
face and in their paper they report that
their model can actually outperform
physicians when Tess
on a set of images that are would be
relevant to a clinical scenario and one
reason that work like this is really
exciting is because it presents sort of
another standard approach standardized
approach to identifying and diagnosing
in this case genetic disorders and you
can imagine that this could be combined
with already existing clinical tests to
improve classification or subtyping
alright so to summarize what we've
covered in today's lecture we first
considered sort of the origins of the
computer vision problem and how we can
represent images as arrays of brightness
values and what convolutions are and how
they work and we then discussed the
basic architecture of convolutional
neural networks and kind of went in
depth on how cnn's can be used for
classification and finally we talked a
bit about extensions and the
applications of the basic CNN
architecture and why they have been so
impactful over the past several years so
I'm happy to take questions at the end
of the at the end of the lecture portion
you feel free feel free to come to the
front to speak to Alexander or myself so
with that I'm going to hand it off to
him for the second lecture of today
[Applause]